I have an a Philly group chat that is
still having this fight I'm gonna give
you two names I just want you to pick
one tío McNabb I'm sorry what type of
question is that my group chat wants to
know who you still are debating this no
not even fault all right you got a pick
a side
well no I Don is my man okay and I love
T so it's obviously no slight on T but
down your reaction to that question
though
it's isn't it interesting that that
questions lasted 15 years everybody
wants to know what was the beef about
and why can't these guys get along
obviously there was potential Super Bowl
caliber players that's one team they're
always potential it got broken up way
too early that's that's everybody asked
me yes yes I'm gonna be okay really tell
me why when I look at the fall of the
mid 2000s Eagles okay there was a line
drawn in the sand yeah and I look now at
it and I go tio has always lived his
truth and now as I retro actively look
at McNabb who I know is your guy and I
appreciate everything you've done for
the organization I don't know how much
was real I don't know how much was media
manipulation I've seen a lot of guys
from your team side with tio and that's
I think impacted me a little bit and I
am unfortunately a Donovan hater just
when I had to decide I went with I went
with tio cuz I thought he was a dog and
that was him and Donovan I feel like I'm
being lied to sometimes that's my truth
it really hurts I'm sweating though cuz
I know that this is my paradigm well
this is even more of the story I think
that there was a big issue for tio about
his contract yes and he wanted in a way
Donovan to back him up on his contract
like oh why wouldn't you aren't you
paying this guy and I think if you don't
put the player in that position and I'm
not talking about tio I think of Joe
banner says listen you come out and you
played in the Super Bowl on a broken leg
please just Ju yeah well why would you
why would we ever make you be in a
situation where you have to ask somebody
else to help you you're the best
receiver that we've had it here ever yes
we're gonna just pay you
there's no rift at that point we go on
to win down to
I think people have disrespected down in
a lot of different ways I think he was
the obviously the catalyst to our
football team he was the guy that played
on a broken leg he was a guy that got us
out shelters all of the places that we
we were we wouldn't have been the team
that we were without that guy and
truthfully the franchise wouldn't have
won as many games throughout the 2000s
sure without that there's no there's no
doubt about that and people expressing
me Philadelphia I don't think they've
respected enough you don't respect it
enough no well no I'm I'm one of the
rare Philadelphia people that will go
I'm open and like I'm willing to change
in the more Eagles that I talk to from
that era I'm just trying to find more
information it's really making me
dislike Joe Banner one of my biggest
regrets obviously there was a big rift
between tio and Donovan
yeah big rift for whatever reason now
being 39 I felt like I could have
probably said something to Don in the
tea both of two of my good friends on
the team and said maybe we can just find
some middle ground and squash this beef
so that we can have a we can realize our
bigger goal which is winning yeah right
and unfortunately I didn't do that and
you know as men I think we all would
have do something different
10 15 years ago but at the time there
was a lot going on back in the locker
room though that was it was like there
was a there was part of the team that
was like I'm on teo side or not it was
you know how teams are you have to all
be headed in the same direction at the
same time yeah and we weren't at that
time and it was bad in it takes a
multiplet of guys to step up and say RK
we're not gonna do this they take on
Donovan is all wrong yeah good nothing
but I think your premise is wrong it
shouldn't leave tomatillo or Donovan no
I mean to me why couldn't we find a way
to keep it all together somehow yeah I
feel so cathartic for me you feel better
yeah I don't know is that too much for
you
no it was good I just I want you to
change your views a little I will yeah
we're working on working on it's been
four years be it takes time yeah slow
progress for one of the greatest
multi-dimensional running backs that
I've ever played the NFL I'll do just
that appreciate the spark you love me
thank you